bonjour il s'agit de la distribution
d'eau c'est sacha et natacha nous
pouvons vous apporter un peu plus d'eau
en avez vous besoin
avant la guerre avec la russie sacha de
diriger sa propre agence d'événementiel
actuellement avec son fils nikita ils se
servent de sa fourgonnette pour
transporter l'eau à travers mikolaj
depuis près de trois semaines la
majorité des habitants font la queue
devant de différents points de
distribution de la ville pour se
ravitailler en eau ceux qui ne peuvent
pas se débrouiller seuls confrontés sur
l'aide des bénévoles comme sa charge
ce n'est pas de l'eau potable utilisé là
seulement pour le lavage
pour des personnes comme tatiana ce coup
de main est une aubaine
j'ai une maladie qui atteint mon système
nerveux et qui m'empêche de bouger
je peux me déplacer un peu dans
l'appartement mais sortir c'est
difficile
sacha travaillent main dans la main avec
une association de bénévoles connu sous
le nom de dof elle a vu le jour après
que le gouvernement ukrainien et
demander aux citoyens au tout début de
la guerre de l'aider à construire des
tchèques tomas à fabriquer des cocktails
molotov 9 répondent à tous les besoins
quels qu'ils soient y compris ceux
venant des volontaires de la défense
territoriale
le gouvernement nous aide du mieux qu'il
peut mais il y à des interruptions donc
nous avons besoin de nourriture de
conserves de vêtements d'uniforme cette
activité se poursuit à l'intérieur du
bâtiment où les volontaires se sont
installés compte tenu de sa proximité
avec le front nicolas accueille beaucoup
de déplacés qui arrivent avec de maigres
bagages
malgré le fait que ce lieu soit
aujourd'hui à moitié en ruine dans deux
ans il aura 200 ans et nous espérons
pouvoir le restaurer nous espérons que
la guerre sera terminé et que nous
pourrons célébrer notre victoire
l'homme derrière cette initiative et
vladimir un pianiste de jazz qui espère
que l'association survivra aux conflits
actuels
malgré le fait que ces lieux soient
aujourd'hui à moitié en ruine il en deux
ans il aura 200 ans et nous espérons
pouvoir le restaurer nous espérons que
la guerre se terminera et que nous
pourrons célébrer notre victoire
pour beaucoup de volontaires ici à
nicolas yves la première victoire c'est
d'avoir réussi à unir leurs efforts
autour de tels projets mais avec
l'ambition russe de vouloir avancer vers
le sud de l'ukraine considérait toujours
comme une cible majeure cet élan
humanitaire à lui seul risque d'être
insuffisant on s'apprête ici